depuis un an dans la crise sanitaire est
venu jouer les trouble fêtes
rassemblements interdits couvre-feu
confinement pour les organisateurs de
mariage la note est salée entre reports
ou annulations en cascade
beaucoup accusent le coup malgré des
aides de l'état leur chiffre d'affaires
a chuté drastiquement
d'autant que la visibilité est nulle
quand à la fin de l'année paul boyer le
grand flou sur l'organisation des
mariages inquiète les mariés et bouscule
toute l'économie du secteur
constat amer que dresse ce film est la
fondatrice de l'agencé s&p wedding et
futurs mariés ils sont pas du tout
serein et s'appuie sur nous
professionnels pour avoir des
informations et savoir dans quelle
direction ils doivent aller donc c'est
super important aujourd'hui pour nous
d'avoir une visibilité sur un calendrier
potentiel d'une reprise qu'on puisse
voilà pas laisser nos clients sans
réponse en fait dans le mariage il ya
aussi une crainte de la part des mariés
il ya une crainte pour 2021 2022
ils se posent encore des questions donc
si madame travaille pas moi je
travaillais pas non plus parce qu'en
fait elle à m'amener un client voiliers
et s'initie à la même personne bas donc
en fait c'est une boule de neige depuis
plus de dix ans les duc de richelieu
organise des mariages de concert avec le
traiteur la fleuriste ou encore le
camping de la commune
c'est tous ces acteurs qui sont
directement frappés par la crise né dans
une petite commune richelieu et
finalement on travaille beaucoup en
local on a un hôtel restaurant qui fait
traiteur donc le fait d'une fureur de
mariage fait que lui il travaille
beaucoup moins en termes de traiteur il
ya moins de location de chambres le
terrain de camping est situé à un
kilomètre de nous c'est en moyenne dix
personnes qui viennent dormir sur le
terrain de camping lorsque nous on a un
mariage donc c'est une valve à une perte
économies pour tous ces acteurs là
parmi eux olivier blanc traiteur situé à
800 mètres de la salle de réception a vu
son chiffre d'affaires divisé par 2 du
fait des annulations successives de
mariage les mariages dans un premier
temps ont été reportés sur l'automne à
chaque fois qu'on a pu le faire et puis
finalement la crise continuant sur
l'automne dernier les mariages ont été
soit reporter à nouveau soit purement et
simplement annulée l'entreprise locale
qui tournait autour de 30 mariage par en
appuyant n'effectuer qu'une dizaine
depuis mars dernier
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne partie de la
commune qui est dans le flou tous
espèrent un assouplissement des mesures
dans les prochaines semaines